that's right flex on them rebel yeah i'm
good this year i'm concentrating on
health rebel wilson is continuing to
prioritize health in 2022 the actress
took to her instagram story on tuesday
to share clips of her and her sister
anakie wilson's recent waterfront
workout in front of australia's sydney
opera house
as you can see rebel runs in place as
anarchy strikes opposed with a peace
sign as the two are standing under the
sydney harbor bridge great way to bend
calories guys in addition to the bridge
and opera house the location is also the
site of the upcoming rebel theater which
was named in the actress's honor and is
set to open in february now rebel that's
real flex
it's cool according to a press release
rebel donated 1 million dollars toward
the cost to build the theater which will
be the new home of the australian
theater for young people a group she's
long been involved with that's right now
back to rebels workout sesh these clips
come after she lost 77 pounds during her
self-proclaimed year of health which she
began in 2020 but in december the 41
year old revealed that not everyone was
supportive of her weight loss
i got a lot of pushback from my own team
actually here in hollywood the
australian actress opened up on bbc
breakfast about how her team initially
reacted to her decision to focus on her
health and lose weight when i said okay
i'm gonna do this year of health i'm
gonna i feel like i'm really gonna
physically transform and change my life
and they were like why
why would you want to do that because i
was earning millions of dollars being
you know the funny fat girl and like and
being that person revel noted that
although she felt extremely confident
before her weight loss she knew that
some of her eating habits weren't
healthy i struggled a lot with emotional
eating this is something she opened up
about a few months prior to her bbc
interview when she appeared on the
australian morning show sunrise the
actress went on to detail how her
decision to make healthier choices has
changed her life dramatically i went to
the doctors and got my yearly checkup
last week and he's like oh my god all
your labs and your blood work is like
the best it's ever been and
you just you know it's kind of
remarkable so i i don't know i'm proud
of myself for doing it and also
maintaining it et spoke with rebel back
at the start of 2020 at the oscars when
her health journey was just beginning
it's the year of health for me
so it's a slow it's a journey um but no
i feel good even though i've traveled
all around the world in the last few
days but
you look amazing
[Music]
you